bonjour patrick pour mieux jouer merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france vous êtes
évidemment un soignant également d'un
syndicat à votre réaction quand même à
ce qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
et suite aux propos d' emmanuel macron
bien disons que tout est assez minable
quand on voit que le travail est
extrêmement difficile dans les hôpitaux
l'un des réalités qui sont une réalité
sociale sociétale et les réalités
d'avoir des bateaux cette pathologie qui
est extrêmement violente avec un afflux
de talisman qui est un affluent
extrêmement forte avoir des gens qui
s'employait cette façon là et surtout
des propos qui sont extrêmement
méprisant pour une partie de la
population alors on a tous essayé de se
rassembler dans une période extrêmement
difficile on trouve sa relation minable
je pense que d'autres priorités que le
président de la république ferait mieux
de s'intéresser plutôt à savoir de
quelle moyenne qui se donne les moyens
réellement pour lutter contre cette
pandémie il n'a pas le sentiment en tout
cas que dans ses propos sur les moyens
qui sont mis sur la table de façon
coordonnée et surtout un moule à
permettre à chacun et à chacune de 2 %
sortiront le débat tourne autour de
vacciner versus non vacciner à l'hôpital
pour vous c'est vous fait pas la
différence finalement entre ces
populations il n'en faut pas faire la
différence entre autre enjeu c'est de
soigner c'est de prendre en charge toute
la population d'où qu'elle vienne
quelles qu'elles soient et quels que
soient ses antécédents à partir de là
nous avons eu une obligation qui est une
obligation de prise en soin et surtout
de donner les moyens qui sont les moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir s'occuper pour
pour faire le maximum pour pouvoir
sauver des gens mais pour pouvoir
éventuellement les soigner il y avait ça
c'est notre travail est justement alors
ce que vous déplorez c'est qu'on n'avait
pas ses moyens ses moyens sont
insuffisants les appelle justement pour
l'hôpital date est d'ailleurs bien de
bien avant la crise sanitaire mais on a
à nouveau à faire un ministre qui à
l'époque était député donc il est y
compris député dans une autre parti
politique qui depuis des années s'est
mis en situation de ne pas souhaiter
entendre ce qu'on avait à dire je vous
rappelle pour mémoire le ségur de la
santé à 18 mois ou le demandions
d'urgence un plan de formation pour cent
mille professionnels pour arriver à
colmater les difficultés qu'ont les
hôpitaux pour pouvoir faire leur travail
correctement on voit aujourd'hui au pied
du mur qu'on est face à une situation d
extrêmement dramatique et devant
laquelle le gouvernement se retrouve
totalement démunis sauf à essayer de
trouver des mesures sont des mesures qui
ont des pis-aller donc à partir de là
nous on estime que le gouvernent on n'a
pas fait correctement son travail on
estime que la ministre des solidarités
la santé est entièrement responsable une
situation de dégradation complète de
l'hôpital public et surtout d'une
dégradation complète de la possibilité
pour la population de trouver des lieux
pour se soigner et à partir de là chacun
doit en tirer les conséquences et chacun
doit surtout se mettre autour de la
table et c'est la peine qu'on lance à
nouveau ont mis sa solidarité à santé
c'est la peine qu'on va lancer au
premier ministre le 11 janvier lors de
la journée d'action c'est une action
forte sur laquelle on va demander bien
sûr un goûter le premier ministre et
c'est l'appel que lance au gouvernement
pour pouvoir vraiment rentré dans des
discussions qui sont des discussions qui
permet de parler de l'hôpital public les
personnels des effectifs des salaires et
pas forcément simplement de petites
chicaneries qui se passe soit dans la
presse soit sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale pour vous si ces mesures
avaient été prises si le métier d'aidé
soignant avait été revalorisée et et
donc il n'y aurait pas eu non plus cette
hémorragie de personnels soignants des
hôpitaux à cause du surtravail des
heures supplémentaires pour vous on n'en
serait pas là on n'en serait pas à
stigmatiser des non vaccinés c'est pas
forcément de la probabilité entouré la
non vaccination et savoir s'il faut les
stigmatise une par mois je n'ai pas la
compétence ni les capacités à vous
répondre ça relève pas du tout de mon
domaine à savoir si c'est réellement
indispensable c'est utile ou si
simplement annexes je me permettrai pas
de rentrer dans ce débat la réalité
c'est de nous l'obligation que nous
avons c'est quelle que soit je vous le
dis les populations d'où qu'elles
viennent notre responsabilité c'est de
prendre soin à partir de là nous devons
avoir les moyens nécessaires qui nous
permet de le faire de façon correcte de
façon surtout de sécuriser et qui nous
permettent de faire sur tout le
territoire avec une équité de traitement
sur le territoire et là on est dans une
situation où c'est tous ces éléments là
ne sont plus réunies pour la situation
l'hôpital public est dans une démarche
où il peut plus arriver à fonctionner
correctement et au regard d'une démarche
surtout où les professionnels quittent
l'hôpital public faute de pouvoir y
travailler de façon correcte et je vous
pour aller travailler de façon décente
et qu'ils ne soient pas en opposition
avec les valeurs que nous portons qui
sont des valeurs du soin que les valeurs
du centre et clairement que nous
mettrions pas qu'ils nous soignons et
nous réfléchissons pas à savoir quelles
sont les origines et sur les conditions
professionnelles quelles sont les
conditions sociales quelles sont les
conditions
dessous et un antécédent notre rôle
c'est de soigner alors on va écouter
jean castex qui met en avant toujours le
travail difficile et des soignants en
ces temps de pandémie voyez ce qu'il a
dit à l'assemblée nationale hier
face à bath et mesdames et messieurs les
députés nos soignants engagé qui eux ne
s'arrête pas à minuit
voter
c'est irresponsable
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que dit le
premier ministre évidemment vous ne vous
arrêtez pas à minuit mais à quel prix
c'est pas ses patins le point de vue
prix moi je me rappelle du premier
ministre qui était en face de moi lors
du ségur qui équivaut nous expliquer
gentiment qu'elle m'envoie effectivement
il fallait qu'on fasse des choses qu'il
fallait qu'on revalorise et qui fait
qu'en réfléchissent à la façon dont les
choses devaient se faire mais qu'on
avait surtout limité c'était celle à
pascal moment on n'a pas forcément les
moyens etc etc je pense que les
argumentaires varie en fonction des
saisons et surtout en fonction des
réalités qui ont déjà été médiatique
mais surtout les réalités des histoires
puis on s'aperçoit que l'on convient
d'être déchargé de façon extrêmement
violente sur nos hôpitaux et vous l'avez
dit vous allez à manille
d'hospitalisation il hier on sait
pertinemment que dans les jours qui
viennent la catastrophe annoncée va se
poser sur la table au-delà de ça la
vraie réalité il est un roman c'est une
responsabilité politique notamment du
premier ministre mais aussi du président
de la république gouverner c'est prévoir
il me semble quand même qu'on avait
alerté de façon extrêmement clair
extrêmement honnête en disant que
l'hôpital avait craqué en tutelle ne
tiendrait pas moi je vous dis très
clairement l'hôpital ne tirera pas il
faut qu'on soit un peu réaliste par
rapport à ça ce qu'on soit au clair et
les professionnels qui sont au bout du
bout parce qu'ils ont tenue déjà les
quatre premières vagues ils ont
effectivement depuis lors je vous le
rappelle il ya eu des suppressions de
jours de congés qui ont déjà été
rémunéré beaucoup de personnel ont
travaillé sur les temps supplémentaire
l'épuisement et la mousson épuisement
moral qui sont les plus ou moins
physique que ce soit plié mais
psychologique et à un moment tirer sur
la corde est fière de ces professionnels
les boucs émissaires les situations qui
n'ont pas souhaité qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement difficile et oui dans la
perte de sens et dans la perte surtout
de reconnaissance qu'on peut avoir du
travail effectué mais surtout dans la
perte de ce qu'est la réalité
quotidienne des conditions de travail
les professionnels oui beaucoup sans
gros coussins marseille
soignant en réanimation décidé de faire
grève aujourd'hui ça va être ça va faire
tache d'huile selon vous ça peut faire
tache d'huile on voit que les situations
sont extrêmement hétéroclites et comme
ou qu'on soit en france c'est pas du
tout la même appréhension des choses
dans la région paca qui est ma région ça
tombe bien la situation est extrêmement
explosive si on est sur un taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation qui
au-delà des 100 % donc effectivement
vous avez pu le constater les transferts
qui l'ont fait d'autres régions de
france dont la situation est extrêmement
explosive mais elle est en amont de
situations qui vont devenir explosive
ailleurs donc on le sait pertinemment
c'est qu'à un moment la situation va
craquer la situation inquiète m'est
offert à gré d'une réanimation vous
doutez bien que c'est pas empêché de
soigner les gens il est bien évident
qu'à un moment le mouvement c'est un
mois surtout médiatique pour appeler au
secours
et pour rappeler à nos gouvernants et
surtout aux députés qui sont sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale et qui
sont en train de discuter un texte sur
lequel il entend se battre un peu comme
des chiffonniers quand même moment il ya
des réalités de territoire à ces
réalités de fonctionnement dans les
habits sont ensuite à lille il a ses
réalités suppression définir soi excusez
moi mais rappelons nous que le projet
machination la sécurité sociale qui a
été voté par la majorité il ya quelques
semaines qui est mise en oeuvre depuis
le 1er janvier prévoit à nouveau des
coupes sombres sur les budgets
hospitaliers
comment est ce qu'on peut dire d'un côté
on va soigner tout le monde il va
permettre de sauver la population la
situation le comité dengue qui déferle
partout sur nos établissements
hospitaliers et de l'autre côté dire on
s'attend à réduire les moyens financiers
et ses dichotomie qui sans arrêt posé
sur la table qui fait qu'à un moment la
réalité des choses la réalité s'impose à
tout le monde sait que les
professionnels qu'elles ont ras le bol
il sent bon et surtout que on l'a vu il
ya peut-être d'autres variant à venir
merci beaucoup patrick bourguignon un
sur six avoue je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire fédéral cgt santé et action
sociale